♪ ♪
>> Bret: RUSSIAN
PRESIDENT VLADIMIR PUTIN SAYS HE
HAS NEW WEAPONS THE U.S. CANNOT
DEFEAT.
HE SAYS HE IS NOT BLUFFING.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION, THE
PENTAGON, IS NOT IMPRESSED.
RICH EDSON HAS THE ALARMING
SPECIFICS FROM THE
STATE DEPARTMENT.
>> NEW NUCLEAR POWERED MISSILE.
INVINCIBLE AGAINST MISSILE
DEFENSE.
ALL ACCORDING TO THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT.
VIDEO ANIMATION SHOWS THIS
MISSILE CRUISING AROUND
INTERNATIONAL DEFENSES HEADED
TOWARD THE WEST COAST OF THE
UNITED STATES.
STANDING IN FRONT OF THAT VIDEO
ON BOASTING OF THE CLAIMED
ADVANCES, RUSSIAN
PRESIDENT VLADIMIR PUTIN.
>> Translator: NO ONE WANTED
TO SPEAK WITH US CONSTRUCTIVELY.
NO ONE HAS LISTENED TO US.